مرحباً، أهلاً بكم في الدرس. مرة أخرى، أهلاً بكم. اسمي ديفيد براون وهذا سيكون درساً أصلياً مركباً في القراءة والكتابة والقواعد. أنا سعيد بوجودكم جميعاً هنا. تفضلوا بالجلوس جميعاً. أهلاً بكم.
مرحباً يا هكتور (Hiktur). كيف حالك؟
بخير تماماً. كيف حالك أنت؟
أنا بخير جداً. شكراً لك.
أهلاً بك. أهلاً بك.
شكراً لك.
أرى أنك اخترت درساً عن الحجج (arguments). هل تود أن تتعلم كيف تكون أكثر إقناعاً في درس اليوم؟
أود ذلك. في الواقع، أود ذلك بشدة لأن هذا أمر مهم جداً عند التحدث بلغة أخرى.
نعم، السؤال الأساسي في هذا هو: ماذا نريد وكيف نحصل عليه؟ والتواصل هو الوسيلة التي نكتسب بها الأشياء التي نريدها.
لذا فإن تعلم أن تكون مقنعاً هو حقاً من المهارات الناعمة الرائعة للتعلم.
وهناك إجراءات يمكننا اتباعها من أجل الإقناع بفعالية. لذا في درس اليوم، سنتحدث عن الإقناع بفعالية وعن بعض مهام القراءة والكتابة والقواعد التي يمكن أن تساعدنا على الإقناع بشكل رسمي.
لدينا مفهوم "cohesion" (التماسك - at-tamāsuk)، والتماسك هو عندما يكون الشيء كلاً متكاملاً.
لكي نقدم حجة جيدة، نحتاج إلى أن تكون لدينا جميع أجزاء الحجة.
ونحتاج أيضاً أن تكون الحجة سلسة. يجب أن يكون لها انسيابية (flow). لذا لدينا "cohesion" (التماسك) و "flow" (الانسيابية - al-insiyābiyyah)، وهما مفهومان سنتحدث عنهما قليلاً اليوم.
إذاً، دعنا نستكشف كيف يمكننا تحقيق ذلك.
لدي صورة على الشاشة هنا. تقول "من الأفكار المشوشة إلى وجهة نظر واضحة ومقنعة".
نرى هذا الرجل وغرفته فوضوية.
ستارته هناك ممزقة.
وهي تجعل المكان يبدو نظيفاً هناك.
في الواقع تبدو كغرفتي.
حسناً، حسناً.
حججنا تشبه هذا، أليس كذلك؟
يمكن أن تكون حججنا فوضوية أو يمكن أن تكون منظمة.
وإذا عُرضت حججنا بطريقة منظمة، فمن المرجح أن نقنع الناس بأن شيئاً ما صحيح.
نريد أن نفعل هذا بصدق. كيف يمكننا أن ننظم أفكارنا بصدق لتقديم وجهة نظر مقنعة؟
دعنا نرى ما إذا كنت تتذكر شيئاً عن الحجج أو أخبرني بما تعتقد أنك تعرفه عن الإقناع.
ما هما الجزءان من الحجة اللذان تتذكرهما؟
هل تتذكر أي أجزاء محددة؟
في الواقع، لا أستطيع أن أتذكر.
كما تعلم، مثل أن تكون منظماً جداً.
ودعني أرى الآخر.
قلتَ، منظماً.
وفوضوياً.
حسناً.
والعكس سيكون منظماً، أليس كذلك؟
إذاً أن تكون منظماً مقابل أن تكون فوضوياً.
ماذا عن بنية الحجة؟
كيف تجادل بفعالية؟
ما هو الشيء الذي تحتاج إلى القيام به لتقديم حجة جيدة؟
حسناً، في الواقع، أحتاج إلى، أحتاج إلى جعلها شاملة جداً.
أليس كذلك؟ بالنسبة للشخص المعني.
يستمع إلى حجة واحدة. أليس كذلك؟
ويجب أن تكون سهلة.
للفهم.
وسهلة الفهم أيضاً.
أتفق معك.
لذا إذا قمنا بتحسين بعض هذه الجوانب من القواعد، مثل التماسك والانسيابية، يمكننا جعلها أسهل للفهم.
يمكننا جعلها منظمة وليست فوضوية.
ويمكننا جعلها متكاملة. يمكننا جعلها شاملة.
إذاً هذه هي أهدافنا التعليمية لدرس اليوم.
هل يمكنك قراءة هذا الهدف الأول لنا؟
نعم، أهداف التعلم لليوم.
تحليل حجة نموذجية من حيث البنية والانسيابية.
هل تريدني أن أقرأها كلها؟
حسناً.
استخدام منظم بياني لبناء الحجج.
فهم كيف تؤثر الخيارات النحوية على الوضوح.
والتماسك.
التدرب على استخدام أدوات الربط بفعالية.
وتحديد وتصحيح الأخطاء الشائعة التي تؤثر على وضوح الحجة.
حسناً، دعنا نتدرب على هاتين الكلمتين هنا.
هذه تُنطق، كرر بعدي، clarity, clarity.
أوه، clarity.
حسناً.
وهذه بصوت Jen، مثل Z.
نوع من صوت ZJ، cohesion.
Cohesion و clarity.
حسناً.
نعم، لم ألاحظ أنها كانت.
نفس كلمة clear.
لقد اختلط الأمر عليّ في الواقع.
نعم، إنها مرتبطة بكلمة clear.
لذا clear.
نعم، إنهما مرتبطان.
نفس الشيء.
صحيح.
هذا ما أعتقده.
أهأ.
إذاً لديك clarity، وهي الاسم، وشيء ما clear،
فهي الصفة.
نعم.
حسناً.
إذاً ما يمكننا أن نبدأ به أولاً هو تشريح الحجة.
الأجزاء المختلفة للحجة.
وهذا شيء يمكننا تعلمه.
ونتذكر من أيام الدراسة، عندما كنا نكتب المقالات وأشياء من هذا القبيل.
كيف تبني مقالاً؟
ما الذي يأتي أولاً، ثم تالياً، ثم أخيراً، عندما تكتب؟
دعنا نقرأ هذا الجزء هنا.
هل يمكنك قراءة هذه الفقرة لي؟
بالتأكيد.
الحجة المتقنة تشبه البنية الهندسية الجيدة.
تتطلب مكونات قوية وروابط سلسة.
التماسك يضمن ترابط الأفكار منطقياً.
بينما تسمح السلاسة للقارئ بتصفح الحجة بسلاسة.
حسناً، ممتاز.
لذا صنعت هذه الصورة هنا لتوضيح هذه الفكرة هندسياً.
لذا لدينا فكرة أن الحجة مكتملة.
ولكن يمكن أن تكون الحجة مكتملة، ولكنها لا تنساب بشكل جيد.
يمكن أن تحتوي الحجة على جميع الأجزاء، ولكنها غير مجمعة معاً.
لذا إذا نظرنا إلى كل مرحلة من هذه المراحل، نرى أنها تبدأ ببضعة عناصر غير مترابطة بشكل جيد.
إنها غير مترابطة من خلال الاستدلال الذي نحتاجه.
نرى أنها تبدأ في التكون، ولكن ليس لديها انسيابية جيدة.
وعندما تتحسن الانسيابية، ننتهي بدائرة مثالية.
لذا هذا يوضح فكرة التماسك، وهو كونها كلاً متكاملاً.
الشكل السداسي في هذه الصورة لديه تماسك، ولكنه ليس لديه انسيابية.
هذه الدائرة، من ناحية أخرى، لديها تماسك وانسيابية.
إذاً كيف يمكننا فعل ذلك؟
كيف يمكننا بناء فقراتنا ومقالاتنا؟
بحيث تكون منظمة وتحتوي على جميع الأجزاء التي تحتاجها.
وبحيث تنتقل من جزء إلى آخر بشكل منطقي.
وإذا فعلنا ذلك بشكل صحيح، إذا فعلناه بفعالية، فسيكون لدينا كلا هذين العنصرين ونقوي حجتنا.
لذا لدينا هذه العناصر الحجاجية، قطع الأحجية، التماسك، أي البنية الرابطة، والانسيابية، أي التدفق السلس بين الأفكار.
حسناً. لذا نحتاج إلى تذكر هذه المكونات الأساسية للحجة.
دعنا نقرأ هذه هنا. هل يمكنك قراءتها لي؟
بالتأكيد. هل يمكنني القراءة من البداية؟
مثل استدعاء المكونات الأساسية للحجة: الادعاء (claim - al-iddiʿāʾ)، الحقائق (facts - al-ḥaqāʾiq)، الخلفية (background - al-khalfiyyah)، الأطروحة (thesis - al-uṭrūḥah)،
الجمل الرئيسية (topic sentences - al-jumal ar-raʾīsiyyah)، الأدلة (evidence - al-adillah)، الأمثلة (examples - al-amthilah)، الدحض المحتمل (potential rebuttal - ad-daḥḍ al-muḥtamal)،
والخاتمة (conclusion - al-khātimah). الفهم الراسخ لهذه العناصر أساسي.
جيد جداً.
إذاً لدينا "claim" (الادعاء). كلمة أخرى لـ "claim" هي "thesis" (الأطروحة).
لدينا "background" (الخلفية)، وهي سياق ما نتحدث عنه.
إذا بدأنا الحديث وبدأنا الجدال، ولكن لا أحد يعرف ما نتحدث عنه أو خلفيته، فلن يكون الأمر واضحاً.
لذا نبدأ بـ "claim" (الادعاء).
يمكننا تقديم بعض المعلومات الأساسية حول ذلك.
ثم لدينا "thesis statement" (بيان الأطروحة).
هذا بيان أطروحة وهو بشكل أساسي الحجة الرئيسية للشيء بأكمله الذي نحاول إقناع الشخص الآخر بتصديقه.
لذا فإن الإقناع هو إقناع شخص آخر بتصديق شيء ما.